- [Interviewer] All right, JD,
JD where you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- [JD] Originally from
Rural Mountain, Tennessee.
- [Interviewer] And did you
have the Klan growing up
in your family as a kid?
- [J.D.] Yeah, somewhat
on my grandparents side.
- [Interviewer] How did you get involved?
- Well, around 2015 or so,
when Dylan Roof, he's took
and shot the black people
in Charleston in that church,
and every picture that I saw on TV of him,
he was having the
confederate flag in his hand
and he never was a member
of any organization.
And then they go and take the flag down
in South Carolina off the
state capital building
because of that and I thought maybe,
that was kind of a slap in the face
to the south, to our ancestors
that fought in the Civil War.
I had people on both sides
of my family that fought
in the Civil War for
Tennessee and North Carolina,
and in 2017 I joined
the Loyal White Knights,
and I just wanted to
get out and try to make,
do my part and try to make a difference.
Like I.W. was saying, if
we don't pull together
it's gonna be a like a sinking ship,
our rights are going
down the drain every day
and I just wish my grandparents was around
to see me and know that I'm doing my share
and trying to preserve our history.
And I don't consider
myself really as a racist,
I'm more of a separatist,
I believe in keeping the races separate.
That's what God intended,
that's why he put us
on different bodies of
land, different language.
Just different cultures all together.
And I believe that the white race
is a superior race, and that's just,
that's kind of the way
I feel about it, so.
- [Interviewer] What do you
wish the United States looked like?
- Sorry?
- What do you
wish the United States
looked like racially,
I mean right know we're all very mixed.
- Yeah, we're very mixed,
I just wish that they could
stay more to their self.
- When you say they?
- Don't try to push
'em down my throat, you know?
- [Interviewer] When you
say they, you mean--?
- Our government, and not our government,
but the black race, the
Hispanics, the Orientals,
I wish that they would
stay with themselves.
And I think the country
would be a lot better off
if it was like that, and
Lincoln, he freed the slaves,
he was from Illinois, so
I think they should've
gave that state to the slaves
and let 'em all go to Illinois
if that what he preferred.
I think right now it's a slippery slope
and if the white people
don't get out there
and try to make a difference,
we're gonna give our
history, our heritage away,
I mean, it's gone.
But you know, I just wish that more people
would see the light and see
where this country's heading,
because I give it another 10 years,
we'll not be able to do
what we're doing today.
It's probably gonna be a felony
to be seen in the Klan hood, so,
I mean it's just a matter of time.
- [Interviewer] What is the
Klan's biggest issues today?
Is it immigration?
- Well, we're strongly against--
- Race mixing.
- you know, mixing races,
messing with our monuments,
our flag, our history,
especially in the South,
because we were originated
in the South in Palaska, Tennessee
and being from Tennessee, you know,
the Klan's always been
strong in that state,
and in North Carolina, and I just wish
that we had a better opportunity
to get out there and make a difference,
because they, they're not
wanting to issue us permits
and stuff like that to
have rallies or anything,
or public demonstrations,
but you've got all this
protesting stuff going on,
and they're just out here
doing what they wanna do
and tearing up the country,
and nothing's said, I
mean it's not the Klan,
there's a lot of these other groups,
they're not doing that.
- [Interviewer] Are
you a religious person?
- Yes sir.
- [Interviewer] The Klan's
a religious organization.
- Yes sir.
- [Interviewer] What
aspects of Christianity
is the basis for the Klan?
- Well, I'm Souther Baptist.
I'm basically Baptist, I mean,
there's Methodists,
Presbyterians, you know,
no Catholics, I mean, it's.
- [Interviewer] And you
are a Imperial Wizard,
or a--?
- No, I'm a Grand Dragon,
I'm over North Carolina
and South Carolina.
- [Interviewer] What do you do, okay?
And what is a grand dragon?
- It's the state officer,
I'm over the state,
and I'm right under the
Imperial Wizard, you know.
- [Interviewer] So what is
it about African Americans,
that you want them to be separate?
- Well, I don't think God intended
for them to be mingling with us
and especially to be breeding
with the white race.
It brings about a mongrol
race, I mean a mulatto color.
Nothing makes me any sicker than
to see a little kid running around
and their skin's just yellow.
I mean a mulatto color.
I mean, I wouldn't feel
so bad about the blacks
if the government wasn't
pushing them down our throat.
Just like in the 60s, I mean,
they pushed them down our throat
and the schools and cafes, restaurants,
and it's just something that I don't think
should've ever happened.
- [Interviewer] How has the Klan changed?
I mean you've only been
a member for a few years.
- I've been, yeah several years,
but the Klan's really changed a lot,
we're not as violent as we used to be,
back in the 60s they was
some violent Klan groups,
especially in Mississippi.
And it gave the Klan a bad rep,
but today we're more laid back.
And it's not a more of a terrorist group
than what they used to be, they claim
that we're in between
in Nazis and Al Qaeda.
We're ranked number two in the world
as one of the worst terrorist groups.
I don't see how they
could rank us up there
like Al Qaeda, or the Nazis.
I mean we don't go out
and just kill people.
- [Interviewer] Have you
traveled to other countries?
- No, I've never been in another country,
but I've been all around
the southern states.
I've not lost nothing up
north, I'm not going up there.
- [Interviewer] So what do
you think about the state
of our country, and its future.
- Right now, I think it's,
it's gonna eventually end up in turmoil
and Donald Trump, he talked
a good talk at first,
that got him into, that
got him into office.
- [Interviewer] You'd be voting for Trump?
- Yeah, I'll vote for
Trump, I did the first time,
I will this time, I
hope he's got a chance.
I mean I've never known a president
to go into office and
so many of his own party
be so much against him.
And wouldn't let him do what
he said he was gonna do.
Like I said, he talked a good talk,
that's what put him in there.
But if he gets in there
again on the next go around,
I hope that he can go ahead
and do what he set out to do,
especially with the border wall.
We've got a bad problem with immigration,
and dealing with China,
I think that was one
of the worst things we ever done
was passed that NAFTA bill
that free trade agreement,
because it took a lot
of our textile workers,
our jobs away from the textile workers,
and sent them to China, Mexico,
and you can't even go to
a store and buy anything
that's not made in China, Taiwan, Mexico,
and especially clothes.
I remember Rocky Boots and stuff,
I hunt a lot and I always tried
to have a good pair of insulated boots,
and even Rocky Boot company,
they're made in China now.
I mean, they need to, we need a president
that will bring our jobs back
and I think the country
would be better off
and give the people here the opportunity
to go back to work.
If they would stop the
immigrants from coming in here,
that would make a big difference.
Finish that border wall.
I mean I'm all for that.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- No sir.
- [Interviewer] No kids, you're married?
- No?
- [Interviewer] What are you
proudest of in your life?
- Sorry?
- What are you proudest of
in your life?
- What am I proud of?
Well I'm proud that I'm white,
that's one of the main things I'm proud of
and I'm proud that I come
from the family I came from
with the background
and I've got ancestors that fought
in the Civil War for the South,
I mean everybody says that
slavery was the main issue
in the Civil War.
It could've been part, but myself,
I think it was mainly over
the money and state's rights.
We had the cotton, the tobacco,
all the agriculture down here.
And taxes, they probably
wasn't paying the taxes
on their stuff and but that's,
if I can make a dollar and get by with it,
I'm gonna do it.
They knew that once they
pulled from the Union,
when the southern states seceded,
that's what they were seceding over.
The taxes, states rights and
I'm not gonna leave slavery out
I'm sure slavery had a part to do with it,
but the North had slaves,
we got a lot of our slaves
from the North.
Even our presidents, Grant,
when he became president,
he didn't give up his slaves
until he got nominated
to be president, I mean.
Then he gave his slaves up, what?
Four, five years after the civil war?
I mean they just, they tell,
just like Robert E. Lee said,
the victors of war will write the story.
And I remember growing up in school,
all the books that we studied in school
was published from up North.
They wasn't none of the books
published from down here.
They tell you what they want you to learn,
and that's why the people today,
they don't know their history,
if the blacks had any clue,
and if they had had enough sense
to open a book and study history,
they wouldn't be going out here and voting
these democrat tickets, because the Klan
was founded by democrats,
a republican freed 'em.
But they're so much against
the republican party,
the part that freed 'em, you know?
It's got a lot to do with the history
and they're not teaching it in the school
and that's what our younger
generation's gonna grow up
to see, a bunch of lies.
That's my opinion, I'll go
to my grave feeling that way,
and it's a shame what
we're gonna leave the kids
for the future, the
shape it's gonna be in,
this country's, I see every day,
it's getting worse and worse.
- [Interviewer] Were there
every lynchings in the Klan?
- Well I'm sure there were years ago.
There have not been no
lynches in, I'm gonna say,
50, 60 years.
But most of the lynchings
was more down south.
Like I said, a lot of the
other Klan groups years ago,
they did give us a bad name.
But as far as lynching going on today, no.
You couldn't get by with it.
- [Interviewer] One of the things
that's interesting about Klansmen,
is that they're so committed
to what they believe.
- Oh I'm into what I believe.
I got a heart of a
Klansman, and I will die
for a Klansman fighting for my race.
- [Interviewer] I mean
you may believe things
that other people may have
a hard time swallowing,
but you believe what you believe
and you stand behind it.
- Exactly, yes sir.
I believe that God, he
gave his life for our sins,
I believe in God.
And as long as I've got God on my side,
I'm all right, as long as I believe
that I've got God in my heart,
and I know that there is a God.
I think I'll be all right.
But the blacks, one thing
they don't understand
about the white culture,
we may have brought 'em
over here, well not me, but you know,
years ago, our ancestors
brought 'em over here,
used 'em for slaves,
but you think about it,
we brought 'em over here and taught 'em
how to worship God, comb
their hair, brush their teeth,
clothe, taught 'em English, tried
to teach 'em right from
wrong, but that didn't work.
They're such a primitive race, they were
so used to living off the land in Africa,
and they should be thankful
that some of them were brought
into the United States,
and kind of what I call domesticated,
they've been domesticated,
and if they don't like it,
I'm sure that we could probably use
some of those big cruise
ships and send 'em back.
I'd put in a few dollars
to put fuel in them ships.
- [Interviewer] So, what
minorities are you at odds with?
African Americans, Mexicans--?
- Well, any race that's not an Aryan race.
- [Interviewer] Well what
about the American Indians?
We kind of stole their country.
- Well, I know it was wrong for us
to come in and push
them off their property,
and do like, the Trail of Tears,
that was pitiful, the way
they done the Indians,
if I'm gonna have any
sympathy for any race,
it will be the Native Americans.
And I know that, but you
gotta think about it, too,
the confederates didn't
do that to the Indians,
the North done it, the Union
done it after the Civil War.
So, if anybody's to blame,
you blame the Yankees.
The North, they're the ones that done it.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever
had any minority friends?
- Well, yeah I have.
I still got a few black guys
that I communicate with.
I don't go out of my way
to communicate with 'em.
If I see them in the store,
I speak, they speak to me,
they know what I'm doing,
they know who I am,
what I represent.
They've so far none
of 'em's ever questioned
me, said anything bad.
- [Interviewer] I've had some
of my African American friends
watch some videos on
my channel of Klansmen,
and they've said that
they respect his stand
and his belief in what he believes,
even though they don't agree
with it, they respect his--.
- Believe it or not man, I've
got a couple black friends,
they care as much about their black race
as I do about the white race.
They don't believe in race mixing.
Some of them are like that.
They don't believe in it,
because they know it's wrong,
they know the bible, they know why
they were in Africa, and we
were in Scotland, Ireland,
'cause we're immigrants
to this country, we are,
but we've built this country.
And right now we're handing it out,
we're just giving it away.
And it's a slippery slope,
I'm telling you, man.
We're kissing our heritage,
we're kissing it goodbye,
every day you see more and more
of these monuments taken down
and street names changes,
and what are they doing?
They're turning right around
and naming those streets
after black people,
and just like Stone Mountain, Georgia,
it's a matter of time they're
gonna blast that mountain,
they'll probably put a
monument of Martin Luther King
on top of it and right
now we're not even allowed
to go in there, and it's not right.
- [Interviewer] All
right, J.D, well thank you
for talking with me,
- Yes sir, man.
- and good luck
with everything.
Enjoy your--
- White power.
- [Interviewer] Enjoy your
cross lighting tonight.
- [J.D.] Yeah, I will, hook you a 10, man.